all right welcome to a very special
edition of a beginner breakdown I am
your host Mike comer and tonight we'll
be talking about how a defense if you
establish a defense early on you'll be
able to win easier okay so in the first
game or show we'll show where black is a
higher rated player and he doesn't care
about defense and it gets into a wild
game and then so we're sure kind of how
not to play and then in the other games
will show how how the higher rated
player you know spend a lot of time
playing defense early and then let his
attack flourish later okay so in the
first game white starts out with the
move d4 black plays c6 white plays c4
black plays d5 so then white plays
Knight to c3 okay so so this is a very
common opening here okay the reason why
black doesn't want to take this pawn is
because then it allows the movie for
giving white a big center look at all
the squares he's attacking in a blacks
camp here okay so that's why they don't
just take the point it looks free but
actually after E for it's going to be
very hard to to maintain that pawn
anyway okay so you don't want to give up
your strength here okay so so right now
black has control of efore and black has
control of 'if I've if he takes he no
longer has control of efore all right so
so black plays Knight f6 protects the
pawn and puts another player on this
pivotal efore square so Knight f3 Bishop
attacks the night this is not a good
move of unfortunately it looks good but
what can white play with his knight
how would he play to attack the bishop
here 95 excellent Mario so he plays 95
and and he's just he's doing he's doing
great okay
but luckily white decides they don't
want double pawns they don't want to
play III because it would block in this
dark squared Bishop so they decide to
play Queen to d3 not recommended
so after Bishop takes the knight Queen
takes and and now black can play e6 and
they're not blocking in a light square
bishop because the light square bishop
is a trait okay so they play the move a3
to prevent the pin Bishop to b4 okay so
they didn't want that to happen so they
played the move a three so now pawn
takes c4 he's giving up control of efore
because he thinks black thinks he could
hold on to this pond after E for black
could play well b5 or what else do you
think they play in the game here instead
of b5 what's another way to to one
protect this pawn and possibly win
material so black can simultaneously
protect this pawn and possibly capture
something anybody see it
so so always in bryn you're playing
chess right look for your captures and
your checks very important so so if you
count up all the possible captures on
this board I only see three four black
and only one of them doesn't lose
material that's probably the answer so
anybody see a capture for black where he
doesn't lose material they go and just
shout it out if you think you know the
answer
Queen takes d4 excellent okay
so I want a pawn and I protected this
pawn it's only obviously my queen gets
attacked I mean that's what happens I
would love to take this but
unfortunately the Knights protecting it
and I'm not gonna capture the night so I
just retreat the Queen back but I lost
that pawn but I'm still up up up a pawn
because I've taken two of his and he's
only got one back in return all right so
now I decided I get my night out and
then white what do you think he does
here to get his a nine billion point
piece the King as safe as can be
Castle excellent okay so so now even
though White's down a pawn his King is
safe you know he's got lines to attack
the King some open files here so he's
got to compensation for the pawn for
sure so so I'm playing black right and I
want to get the game over with quick
right so I want to thread checkmate here
there's two different ways I can thread
in checkmate
one's good ones bad what do you think I
do
so obviously night here threatens
checkmate
but the Queen would just take it so
what's the other way to threaten
checkmate
Bishop to d6 putting the Queen and
Bishop in a battery okay when the queen
of Bishop on the same diagonal it's
called a battery and I'm eyeing at this
h2 square so white sees that he's got
different ways to stop it he could put
his Bishop here but that would be no
good because I have two attackers on f4
and he's only got one defender so I
would lose it
or h3 wouldn't stop it cuz I would just
come down and go checkmate so the only
other way to possibly stop it is with g3
okay so so now his threat if I'm not
careful is Bishop here so I might want
to do something about that so I play the
move g5 computer recommended actually so
I'm pretty proud of myself
g5 even though it but now my King won't
be able to castle over there but I'm not
really thinking about castling all I'm
thinking about is getting checkmate so
white plays a really bad move here takes
the pawn so what do you think I
instantly do just take the bishop right
free bishop thank you and so now he's uh
he just lost the piece for no really
apparent reason so so this is when you
really want to punish your opponent's
here okay because cuz they're not there
they're not thinking right at this point
so pilot one blunder and then it all
starts to steam roll down as you'll see
white played pretty decently okay at
least his first you know twelve moves or
so now since he lost the piece you'll
see his plague diminish exponentially
here
all right so rook e1 not too bad he's
threatening a fork here possibly so get
the knight out to attack the Queen and
the bishop and guess what didn't see it
so he retreats to squint he saw it as
gray was under attack but he didn't also
see that as bishops under attack so take
it now how Joe it looks like you know
white just lost another piece but is
there any way he can get this piece back
be three excellent Mario okay good so so
a tactic in chess is called removing the
defender so you see how this Bishop is
being attacked by the Queen it's only
being protected by the knight so if we
can remove him from c-4 by playing b3
for instance that he moves and then boom
we got the we got the bishop so very
good tactic removing the defender or
sometimes it's also called removing the
guard what was played as a attack h4
attacks the Queen so now I bring the
Queen over there to protect the bishop
and the night so now even boobs like b3
don't work so they attack again so move
my queen so obviously I'm attacking g3 a
lot and I'm also attacking an undefended
piece the night so let's say he protects
the knight okay that was good all right
now remember I want to get this game
over quick you know I'm higher rated
than this guy so so I want to thread
thread to do a lot of damage to them
okay so so notice I got my Queen and
Bishop coming down on g3 here okay if g3
Falls his King is gonna fall okay so
who do you think I bring over to attack
g3 here the rook excellent so if if he
ignores my thread here and let's say
plays a four or something you know I'll
just go ahead and take check hope he
goes there and checkmate him
but even if he goes to f1 I'm still in
the money here cuz I'll play check
forking his Queen and King and you know
I'll get well
well I just hope he goes to h1 and
checkmate him if he goes if he goes to
f1 here I might have to
I might have to consider something else
because my bishop is hanging I'll
probably castle and and it's gonna be
tough for him to him to stop all my all
my good threats or maybe I would
calculate it a little more but rook to
g3 I'm preparing to do a lot of damage
so he sees it so he protects g3 anyway
and attacks my knight simultaneously all
right so now so now I Castle okay so now
so now I know cuz I've calculated if he
takes the knight this rook sacrifice
would actually work for sure because
I've got I've got a check and then that
could bring the other rook in and the
game's over okay so that one I actually
did calculate okay so in so he doesn't
take my knight he decides to defend g3
again with Knight to e2 and now who else
besides White's queen is actually
attacking the knight the rook on c1 it
was a discovered attack so now I really
do have to move the knight Knight back
to b6 but you see even though I'm up by
uh you know I got six pieces and he only
has four you know my King really isn't
the safest piece on the board and he
really should be and I mean he's still
got chances to do for some damage here
so so b5 so he's gonna go for it try to
break open the C file and checkmate me
so who thinks I should just take the
pawn on d5
or who knows Wow yeah then that would be
a big mistake
cuz this pawn is in a pin and when poems
or pieces are in pens they're actually
not doing what you think they're doing
so he would take and then he would laugh
and laugh and laugh as I can never take
the back the Queen okay so that's where
he was hoping for
okay but I knew better so I touched my
Queen as if I'm gonna take it and I take
this pawn instead and he's like oh so
game sorry he plays Queen to c3 and tax
my knight and now he's really got piling
on the C file here so I bring the night
up to d5 to attack the Queen and now
Queen to c2 all right moment of truth
here okay so as I said before I have six
pieces he only has four so I'm up a
significant amount of material there's
no real way to say who's on offense and
who's on defense here cuz it looks like
we're both trying to be on offense right
I got the G file but he's got the C file
so none of us are really on offense or
defense or maybe we're both on offense
so I'm up material maybe I'm on offense
but I don't see a checkmate here so you
might as well trade pieces just
consolidate the position and then you'll
be a winner here alright so he takes
back so now you know I'm up a lot of
pieces still but if I don't get a plan
here this this could take all night to
win this position right and if he
manages to just stick me with a bishop
at night at the end and no pawns
I'm not going to be able to checkmate
them because I'm not a grandmaster I
don't know how to check mate with a
bishop on the night and obviously if it
leaves me with two knights it's
impossible so so what am I gonna do so
let's get a plan here if you were
looking for a plan for black here
what do you like what do you what do you
really like about your position here
rather than you have more pieces than
him okay that's a given
okay so so well well what is whites
threat if it was White's move on the
board here first we have to ask
ourselves this if it was white to move
what move would he play instantly nope
but you're kind of on the right track
is there anything remember I always look
for your captures and your checks so
what was he play you take our pawn right
and then but it's not as move so we
can't take it okay so so you're saying
oh let's just protect the pawn no I mean
we could but we have batter okay so look
this can become a passed pawn okay so
that should be our idea get a passed
pawn and win passed pawns are meant to
be pushed as probably everybody's heard
okay so poor [ __ ] so now you got a
passed pawn and now you're doing well so
now he taunts me okay he's like yep you
can't move you can't take my knight okay
but I mean did that move even do
anything
I don't know so so we play King to b8
one to protect our a pond and two so now
this is a real threat now so night back
to b3 so guess what we're going to do we
just got keep pushing the punt
so now Knights up and now now Mario now
we can take his opponent okay it's free
right
and obviously we can't take this because
the Knights protecting of
all right so we're k2 attacks our Bishop
so we got to move it
so we attacked the other rook and now he
decides he's gonna play some ad offense
here okay so so this is what you want
you want your rooks doubled on on a good
line unfortunately the execution just
doesn't work because okay so he's
threatening to play rook takes a seven
but luckily we have a cool move with our
Bishop to neutralize the threat what do
you think it is so you see our Bishop
and basically chest pretty simple if
like what is on the same leg like you
got a dark square bishop right and then
you look and it's like oh man look he's
got his his uh rook on the dark square
in a knight on this dark square on the
same diagonal leg so guess what more
often than not just put that Bishop on
that same line yeah fork double attack
right so I mean he's he's like no big
deal no big deal but it is a big deal
because it killed your whole threat all
right so now we attack his rook
so now the guys just frustrated so he
gets some spike checks in here check one
check two
but his checks really do nothing and now
we take his last hope the pawn so he
takes up here but now we have a simple
wind what move do you think we play here
you think work the d1 check no what are
we trying to do in this position get a
queen so c3 you can take all our stuff
over there we don't care and check get
them out of this little hole here and
check out my just take us stuff check
and now we have checkmate in one move
can we see it
it's the guy you least suspect the pawn
yeah at least suspect have you found the
checkmate yet Bishop f6 checkmate
excellent and and the game is over so
now here's a game another game where
white decides to play really solid and
get castled and the player playing black
just tries to just rush up all his uh
queenside pawns and try to be the champ
that way so let's see how the champ does
playing like that
all right so white plays d4 black
counters c5 Knight f3 knight c6 so this
is called the Sicilian defense there's a
lot of different ways Y can proceed here
you can play Bishop to b5
could play d4 could even play c3 but
white decides bring out his Knight to c3
here okay so black plays the move d6 and
white brings out his Bishop to c4 I the
crucial f7 square here all right so now
black decides I'm gonna try to win the
bishop the old-fashioned way okay so a
six a very a very barbaric trap b5 so so
now black is hoping hoping with all his
might that Bishop goes to b3 and then of
course c4 have you guys done this in
your shop a lot
seeing it alright please don't fall for
it anymore now you know you don't need
to fall for that okay and so so this
just goes this way okay all right
and Bishop d5 so Bishop protects it with
b7 rook e1 and so now black attacks and
so Bishop takes Czech Bishop takes so so
let's look at this position here so
white should be really happy because his
King is safe is nine billion point piece
all safe and so now black says oh I'm
happy too
because I've got the two bishops but
look it's move up let's say nine coming
up for white okay and black really is a
one step closer to castling than he was
that move one you think it's gonna hurt
them or it's like you know that's no big
deal we'll see okay so white plays the
move d4 this is excellent idea when
you're when your king is safe you know
and your opponent is in the center of
the board still sitting there break open
the center because that's where the king
is and you got to do it fast okay cuz if
you wait two or three moves
guess what he played Bishop e7 Knight f6
and got Castle so time is of the essence
okay
don't monkey around so d4 so now black
decides hey I'm gonna attack you again
moving more more pawns but why it's not
having any of it he's gonna make a
threat greater equal to to his own here
so he plays d5 attacking the bishop so
he's like all right I'll take it
he's like all right I'll take it it's
like I'll take it he's like well I
better take it all right
and now here comes the moment of truth
in the game black plays the move Queen
to b6 thinking this is great
I just forked the pawn on c6 and the
bishop on b2 what are you gonna do so
white knows
hey this King is in the center you can't
castle this is gonna be great but if I
just move my bishop back somewhere okay
and then he takes you know even if I try
and move like a five here I can just
play d5 okay
so he's got to act quick so white
decides I'm gonna sacrifice my bishop
for for a great attack here so he can't
resist he can't resist right a free bish
okay so now pawn takes d6 so he's got
two connected passed pawns on the sixth
rank and one of them's threatening check
so but but black is up a bishop for this
compensation here okay so it brings his
queen back to b6
all right so what move does white make
in this position to protect the pawn on
c6 and there's a lot of different ones
right pi c7 no c7 one worked because
then I'll accept take what the Queen
here you could play check check looks so
tempting right but then I get my King
there and he's blocking these pawns from
doing anything
95 yeah it is possible in that position
after d7 check you might play King D
yeah I don't know which one I would play
but you could think about it alright
well you could just play 95 now and
thread d7 check followed by Knight takes
up 7 alright so so now after 95 black
can't handle the pressure anymore you
know if he plays a move like this the
computer will Poli say game's over
yeah d7 check plus 20 points so so we
can't handle the pressure after d7 so so
he just takes the the up pawn here so
Queen takes the bishop obviously so now
so now white has just in one swoop
recovered all the material is sacked and
he still has a crushing attack alright
so so so okay so so blacks like okay I'm
gonna attack your Queen here
Wow is there anywhere this Queen can
even go to safety or is it just this is
just over see this is this is when you
guys see I've seen I've seen players
rated like 1,200 and lower okay you know
they get into a position where they're
actually like plus 20 the computers
probably yelling that they're plus 20
and if if white can't find his one and
only move guess what
he gives up and resigns okay so you
really need to be resourceful when you
play chess all right because you might
be like oh man I I can't find a move
here it looks like my Queens lost
because if it goes there it's gone moves
there it's gone moves there it's gone
moves there it's gone move anywhere on
the D file that's going right so do we
just give up I hope the answer's no so
what's the only move white can make to
save the queen and throw in a checkmate
on top of it table even add insult to
injury
I'll save the Queen and out the thread
checkmate so Knight takes f7 so so if
they takes f7 okay so unfortunately the
work would take the Queen anywhere we
take with check King moves I mean we get
still we can still try from here at
least we get to still play but we don't
have our Queen anymore and we like our
queen
let's see what the computer actually
says about this but everybody's got to
say Black's wedding but you can't you
can't take the pawn here or else you get
you get crushed yeah you get row so
let's see and I'm thinking they'll pie
just play a night night here and they'll
be okay well let's see let's see what uh
what the computer says this will be
something interesting my buddies I'm
nope nope they kind of like well let's
see what they say after my move maybe
maybe they'll very they'll really like
white after my move so they like Knight
h6 let's see after a night that you have
at the moment of truth what what it says
I hate oh because it allowed night two
up seven obviously obviously huh all
right so Knight h6 has to be played our
King to c7 alright but but it's still
equal so so luckily your move didn't
lose the game so that's good that's nice
but yeah you have a move that's that you
know you still have a really good
fighting chance but but you have better
so that was probably the second best
move
some are just gonna give up he's like I
can't save the Queen d7 d7 excellent and
now now the computer is going crazy it
loves that move it's like yes really it
should love it more than I mean it loves
it but it it doesn't love it as much as
I thought it's only giving you up it's
not even saying you're up a touchdown
when you're obviously just crushing so
now it probably doesn't see the next
move so now black plays the dubious
night that f6 here stopping Queen to f8
checkmate but totally missing a
checkmate in two and remember like in
their previous game you know we can have
dreams about sacrificing you know our
our little pieces that are worth one two
three four five six seven eight nine
points to win the nine billion point
piece so what move do we want to make to
win the whole game may into white
manbo remember don't be afraid to give
up material so the way you look at this
is you calculate you look for your
checks and your captures write checks
and captures so so I see like well like
one two three four five I see five
checks on the board all right check one
check two check three check for check
five you find and then you just
calculate from there from those five
variations and it's a mating two puzzle
so go from there
notice this King can't move at all right
can't go there can't go there can't go
there can't go there the Knights got
that square so all you have to do is
essentially put them in a check and he's
gonna be done for you move the rook all
the way right as far as he can go and
then checkmate right excellent good job
all right so did everybody see see in
that game where blacks priorities in the
opening we're backwards right he was
like trying to trap the bishop then he
was attacking the knight on the Queen's
side and white took advantage by busting
open the center getting his rook and
Queen on the open files toward the enemy
King and just decimating them okay so
that was that was good so we were doing
kind of defense in the beginning of the
game here but now we'll see defense you
have to play defense throughout the
whole game obviously right all right so
let's check it out okay we got about ten
minutes for this one all right we'll do
it
efore 'if I've my my student is a goooo
playing the black pieces so let's watch
it from his uh his great perspective
here Knight f3 knight c6
Bishop b5 attacks the the night I did a
my most popular video on YouTube is all
about the worry Lopes so you can check
it out as I explain why and your guys's
level Bishop a4 is not as good as Bishop
takes c6 doubling the pawns and making
uh making blacks life miserable
okay Knight f6 d3 so b5 you can't resist
attacking the bishop right okay so
Bishop back and now the bishop is eyeing
this crucial f7 Square okay so so if he
just ignores it and plays like fish up
to b7 now the knight can come in and we
can get into a fried liver type position
here so he doesn't want that to happen
so he immediately plays the move
d5 because we've gone over the fried
liver extensively so so now white plays
the move c3 here and did that address
anything that uh black just played so
blacks last move was the move d5 does c3
correspond to that at all the answer is
no okay
so so whenever somebody makes a move
right should ask yourself why do you
play that
oh he did that to attack my pawn I
better do something about that either
capture it protect it protect it
something right instead he's like c3 all
right fine
fine if you don't want to do it you want
to take it out take it so takes the pawn
capture back whenever you got these
Queens in a line like this and it's your
move
I mean more often than that just take it
with check okay and you know so he plays
bishop
takes Knight takes and now white plays a
really tricky move plays the move Bishop
to b3 alright so look at that position
so so so what is White's big threat here
it looks like you just played Bishop to
b3 no big deal well yeah you play h6 in
this position to stop or your favorite
f6 to stop the knife for coming to g5
and you're gonna get burned all right
what's chess all about right the lines
what's on the same line and what move
did with piece that he just move the
light squared bishop so where do you
think that light square bishop really
wants to go to f7 you still think f7 do
we have any others or any other ideas
here where that Bishop wants to go d5
yeah on the same length as all of
black's pieces right so if you play like
h6
boom you just got fourth okay and if you
save that one boom you lose another
piece all right so you gotta watch out
for that when you got all these pieces
on the same leg you gotta wait there one
a punish you with that okay so so now
you finally identified the threat right
so that's step one Mario step two is how
are you gonna stop this from being a
reality
Bishop e6 it looks dreadful but I think
it is the best move yeah Bishop b7 I
guess might work even Knight to c5 but
but you know you know it stops it right
so obviously he takes and doubles your
pawns this is not not the pawn structure
you're looking for right double isolated
pawns double pawns are generally weaker
than regular pawns because they can't
protect each other and not very good all
right and you know if you know if they
become a target guess what you know this
Knight has to sit and guard them the
whole time instead of just pawns protect
another point you want pawns protecting
pawns not not your major pieces cuz they
they got to do damage you know okay so
white plays the move Bishop g5 black
decides not to take it and decides hey
I'm gonna get my own threat Bishop to c5
so how should white actually counter
this threat here what's the best way
because now he's got two men on f2 the
knight and the bishop and he's only got
one defender castle right yeah excellent
more so castle and then if he takes
takes Shaq King takes and white even
though you trade six for six now White
has more pieces than black one two three
four one two three four so you never
want to be trained two for one
unless you're getting a queen then you
can trade two for one all day okay so
the light saw how great
goooo just offended f7 so he decides to
copy you and so he's like alright I'll
take and now you see this is now an
isolated pawn it's kind of just as bad
as a double point as as no point cannot
protect them
all right so black plays h6 doesn't want
anybody coming in to g5 Knight B to d2
attacks the knight retreats the d6 he
decided to cast so long yeah that's why
I played 85 to get an attack going okay
and now b3 and now he castles so now you
got an interesting position here
you got you got the King on the Kings
side and this King on the Queen side so
so they're gonna go for it okay so rook
D to F 1 brick deed F 1
all right so now he's going to try to
get his guys so now what do you think
the last thing black should do here like
what would be the worst plan that black
could ever come up with how about moving
the pawns in front of the King but
that's what's played it and and it makes
his move look genius because he wants to
double the rooks but now he
inadvertently put the knight into a pin
so after g4 if the knight moves by by
rook okay so so he either decides double
his dudes and take rook takes look black
just got up night for pawn so of course
we want to train everything trade trade
trade when you're up trade rook takes up
three so if you're up if you're up if
you're up and he's up guess what he
wants to trade right so offer another
tray rook f8 all right so now rook to be
g3 Shaq okay so this is just gonna be
huge part in this game right white just
check black alright so you could you
could go to the center and get Knight
check some more maybe or you could just
go to h7 and be safe for the rest of the
game maybe well what do you like what do
you like do you want you want to have it
so so your king is
and only has two spaces to go or up and
you know maybe eventually he might check
me on c5 with a knife but I'll have all
these nice squares to go to and just
just you know you can check me all day
look at all these flight squares I have
already you want to just be like I hope
I hope it doesn't get a checkmate here
so what you want to you want to put your
King in the corner or get your king free
like if you go here he gets he gets you
a check and then oh the only check you
might if you get your King ever to here
you might check you over here but yeah
the bottom line is you know what you
want your King to have many many
opportunities to escape it's not like
he's got a queen coming down that can
get you over here
so King to h7 here and white plays d4 so
take take rook F two attacks two pieces
that are protected so not not very scary
so he attacks the knight Knight to f5
attacking the rook and the pawn so rook
the g4 Knight takes III g3 attacks the
knight Knight takes g2 so he's feeling
good but now it allowed white to get an
attack going finally all right Knight to
e4 obviously right attacks the rook rook
to f1 check and so now he plays King the
b2 okay
and now he plays rook to f4 notice
notice in this position if he decided
you know my Knights under attack right
I'll just move my knight to safety
okay
how would white even though he's down a
piece and in a pawn or two two of those
glorious isolated passed pawns well well
well I take it all back I take it all
back if he played rook to g1 to protect
the night here okay now this is the
position I really want you to look at
what move would white make to checkmate
and to and remember check major - we all
know how to solve those pretty easy now
we look for the checks when we see a
he's got three checks all right and then
we calculate out which one actually
works so this check doesn't work this
check he gets taken so yeah Mario you
beat me to the punch you're so good
night of 6 and then King here do is
everybody see a checkmate yeah all
because he decided to leave his King in
the corner yeah a Cobian does that to
people all the time is that good okay so
so luckily black decided hey I'll do the
threat greater or equal to my own right
cuz my my Knights under attack and he's
got this this nasty Knight f6 check may
be coming so after check I'll just
attack his knight and so now he's like
Knight to c3 rook to be four check so
now we know now we know should white
play King a1 King a3 King C to our king
c1
you think you think he should be like oh
I saw I saw my good friend guru doing
this I'll just put my king in the corner
nothing Bad's ever gonna happen here so
that's where he's place he decided tank
it's working out so well for goooo
the King in the corner I'll put my king
in the corner now now this is a little
tougher this is a little tougher this is
a main to problem it might be a little
help but but it's essentially I made too
proud so so can White King move in this
position is a yes or no question no you
can't move anywhere okay so so when a
king can't move is stalemate in
essentially all you have to do is put
that king in check and its mate it's
over kaput okay so now now you're like
alright
our works doing a great job so if we
work would ever give them a check on
this a file guess what the king can go
to the B file and be free okay so so
guess what the checkmate piece isn't
going to be the rook okay so so
unfortunately Mario that would be nice
but oh he just logged we just lost or
night and oh but okay
but what you were thinking we're
thinking if we can get an I don't see to
its mate okay but that's not the night
so what movie you're gonna play in this
position
so Mario figured out hey if I can put my
knight on c2 or even a night on a c4 but
Knight c2 is what we're looking for so
so how can we get a night to see two
let's get it let's get it done and you
might got any ideas we want to get a
knight to this square he won't go to e1
first right and the only way he can
protect c2 right is to play rook to g2 I
bet if I turn on the computer that's
what it's screaming about
and if you play that you would just take
it say plays rook to e3 and the game is
over checkmate so so in the endgame
it's good to have an active King toward
the center not stuck you know on the
middle of the ball are on the side of
the board we're essentially cannot move